the Joe Rogan experience Fame is is a
trick that works on other people but
shouldn't work on you
mmm you got to know who you are on the
percent that's the thing if it works on
you you're [ __ ] because it's like if
you're a magician you really think you
pull the rabbit out of your hat I think
one thing that helps is martial arts you
do to help you it strangled all the time
that word man this is so be using I've
said it but I'm like and I'm like what's
humble cuz I'm special in New Zealand is
this culture of like people even like
they they don't like me because it's all
use notice he's not humble like a true
Kiwis no you know like the All Blacks
you know humble and what they mean and
I've actually put this what does humble
mean and someone said oh you know you
just don't brag I'm like they just mean
downplaying your success
yes you know so if anyone like me rocks
up and just I'm owning it I'm like
throwing it yeah a champ
I'm the more a champ your hand they say
or not he's not humble but I tell you
what humble is when I have Dan hooker on
my [ __ ] neck hangman humble is when I
have Stephen Moore be cracking me with
the uppercut humble is when I have
Carlos kicking me in the body and making
my liver go that's true humility yeah
but mean like trying to act your dawn my
shine just to make someone else feel
comfortable that's not homeboy and I see
that there's a problem with that like
crabs in a bucket thing when tomorrow
was about to win the title a reporter
asks me like you know oh there's a part
of your whole hope that uh komaru loses
so you can be the first Nigerian
middleweight champion I was like [ __ ]
what what reports in the press
conference they actually I was like I
don't think like that that adversity
Lana but that doesn't work yeah he was
hoping I'd say something like that he
was trying to I see them I've been
someone already like I don't do any
interviews with them if they talk to me
I just next i you know I that episode of
black mirror we blocked someone I've
blocked him over with that and you know
record with that they trick they take a
cheap shot they don't understand like
that's you man now you're that guy that
takes those cheap shot yeah and
everybody's gonna remember that yeah
yeah you think you're just trying to get
make some noise make a little pop but
your create
bad energy and also degrees it's not
you're trying to get something from now
you're not thinking along jeopardy yeah
because in the future I'm not gonna talk
to you now
[Applause]